[Music]
there's certain things in society where
it's obvious to people that people are
just born to be it
for me that's that's what
entrepreneurship was
you got your perspective
[Applause]
i just want to be happy don't you want
to be happy
welcome back to the emirates garden i
hope you guys enjoyed that episode of
sweet life but you know what is even
sweeter i get to hang out with gary
vaynerchuk can i call you garyvee or
just you can absolutely all the work
thank you so much for spending some time
for having me i mean what brings you to
the open
uh
novak
the tennis the
passing of summer to fall and you know
i'm a new yorker a jersey ball tonight
yes the wind is coming uh look this is
one of the most important kind of iconic
new york
things yeah you know to me
not getting to the open
is almost like
like would be devastating it's my true
transition from summer life into the
fall
i mean guys we can feel the fall right
now
it is it's kind of like especially when
you grow up here it's kind of it's like
christmas right it's like this thing
that happens year after year
and for me you know i'm in the point of
my life where i see a lot of business
friends and associates here you haven't
seen them because the summer covid
compounds that yeah um
and and i grew up a huge tennis fan and
he did i did and so
i mean one of the few times i cried in
sports that wasn't related to the new
york jets was when john mcenroe lost to
lendl here in 84 i think it was and so
yeah i grew up a very big tennis fan and
uh and i'm excited to be here tonight so
you so
i just want to let everyone know we both
grew up in edison before you moved so
big shout out to big shout outs
did you play tennis growing up i did i
played uh tennis in edison new jersey
three four times a day during the summer
um and
oded wine weinstock if you're watching
eric godfrey if you're watching those
are two gentlemen i played a lot of
matches with in edison new jersey so
yeah i hacked you know uh i have to on
the tennis court
and so you're here tonight to watch
novak is that correct i'm uh you know
for me
immigrant edison new jersey like i very
much associate with the underdog yeah
and when you think of the big three
or the big four if this is airing in the
uk
uh when you think of that novak is
definitely the underdog in the nadal
better novak run so i was i always felt
a huge connection to him yeah plus i
always felt that he played with a chip
on his shoulder a little bit different
than the other guys always spoke to me
has always been my favorite player of
this era and so i'm here sharing them on
today what do you think makes you
gravitate towards the underdog
my reality you know
born in the soviet union
kind of learned english in edison new
jersey
uh
was a bad student
wasn't the greatest at sports so the
world was always kind of telling me
you're not gonna make it and i had this
incredible mother and father and kind of
natural self-belief and
was very fortunate that the thing that i
was great at was entrepreneurship and
business which is a very viable way to
live life is that something you taught
yourself would you say i think a lot of
it was natural dna when you're five or
six or seven years old and you're
selling lemonade on tingling lane or oak
tree road
or shoveling snow
or or
flipping baseball cards in john adams
middle school
we're being very edison nerdy here you
know totally nobody else knows but there
we go my mom wasn't pushing
entrepreneurship on me it wasn't in
culture the way it is now
i didn't read any books it was just so
in me
and and i think that's why i love
athletes
professional singers
you know i think there's certain things
in society where it's obvious to people
that people are just born to be it
for me that's that's what
entrepreneurship was you know i think
we're in the era right now where
everybody wants to be an entrepreneur
right it's a very hot buzzer but for me
in the 80s you know being a bad student
that wasn't cool right but i still
gravitated the way an athlete gravitates
and uh and i've always had that
connection with sports that's really
interesting i i feel like i'm learning a
lot about you gary thank you so i want
to ask you about what you're doing with
the us open and the nfts can can you
explain a little bit thank you for
knowing that uh i've gone pot committed
into nft life
uh had my own project and be friends and
then with the success of that
stood up a company called vayner nft
where we're consulting brands like pepsi
like budweiser like the us open on their
nft programs this one's exceptionally
exciting venus williams billie jean king
and erotic uh incredible tokens of
collectibility and even access to those
icons uh if you buy the one of one uh
incredible launch it's gone extremely
well it's still on sale if you want to
find it and um
i'm really proud of it and it's fun to
see the us open be a first mover in such
a new space yeah um and it's been fun to
see a lot of tennis fans you know i i
constantly read twitter and social media
and a lot of people have bought their
first ever nft with the us open nft and
so it's fun to be part of that history
well so for those of you at home who
don't know nft stands for non-fungible
token
in 30 seconds
if you've ever bought a skin on fortnite
or a power up in a video game you know
what an nft is this is just for the
whole world it's owning a digital asset
which is a new concept yeah but so was
having a website so was having a social
media account these were new ideas of 95
in 2005. this is the newest one most of
the people here aren't
ready comfortable or understand the idea
of owning something just digitally right
but it will be common practice in a
decade i mean i feel like this kind of
harkens back to you selling baseball
cards a little bit
baseball cards comic books and then my
main career was wine
in my early age i built a very large
wine business for my family liquor store
in springfield new jersey yeah and
the reason i was passionate about it was
because people collected wine so to your
point
the concept of collectibility
even sneakers yeah you know by the way
everyone check these out
when
you know what you wear what what you
drive how you roll we as human beings
use physical things to communicate our
status who we are facial hair clothes i
look at everybody behind the cameras
right now i have a sense of them just on
what they wear how they wear their hair
or facial hair
digital assets are the scaled version of
that it's one of the biggest reasons i
believe in nfts so i'm gonna
pivot a little bit to your social media
because obviously there are people
across the world who are
i think they kind of look to you as like
a guru like somebody to follow
like
when did that become a big thing for you
and how do you think it's become such a
success in 2006 i was running the family
wine business and i saw youtube and
twitter and i said these are going to be
huge yeah and so i started making
content about wine
and it exploded i had a comfort with the
camera that i didn't know i had i was
already 31 years old so it wasn't of
mine to be a personality but
i went all in
i believed in it and
and then somewhere around three or four
years later i wanted to talk about other
things besides wine right and i wrote a
book called crush it that basically
predicted a lot of what the world is now
running on
and that book went crazy it was a
one-year new york times best-selling
book
and i started giving speeches and my and
my career changed and really all i am
today
is a byproduct of
incredible mothering all the life
lessons that my mom taught me
all the and really not just mothering
also
really the streets of new jersey and and
the world right i was taught by my mom
and by the streets
and and that is my content today that is
what i talk about
i talk about accountability compassion
my mom is incredibly kind
i think i'm a very unique voice in the
business world around empathy kindness
things that people don't normally talk
about and then on the other hand
i talk about accountability and
self-awareness and
so it's it's positivity but it's
practical right we're not in the
business of eighth place trophies this
is real life and uh and i think people
gravitate towards it well so you
mentioned your first book i did notice
on your social that you were doing some
voice overs for a new year yes today can
you tell us about that one november 16th
a new book called 12 and a half comes
out uh
leveraging the emotional ingredients for
business success okay i i really am
passionate about this unique place i
think i sit in the business world which
is
i don't think that people think that you
know uh curiosity or or empathy are
super powers right i think people think
sharp elbows tough negotiator it's a
doggy dog world and and i don't see the
business world that way i see it from a
framework of
of a lot of soft skills and so it's a
book of why i think emotionally
intelligent soft skills are actually the
alpha skills in today's business world
well you know if if the entire business
world looked at the world that way i
feel like
we would be in a better place i believe
that to be true um so i have to ask you
you know you seem like you don't sleep
very much do you get to take a vacation
i do and by the way on the record i have
high energy when i'm awake but i'm a big
seven eight hour yeah
i think i'm about to sleep i like sleep
i just like being
very productive and on when i'm awake
yeah uh
and i love they i love i love this time
of year because everyone's checked out
yeah
i i only have anxiety when i know the
world is on when i'm not yeah so i type
to be vacations when everyone else is
taking vacations
that's called fomo
yes the only you know
fomo for me of like fun things like at
the us open or ibiza or parties never
fomo of like oh other people being
productive when i'm not yeah
that's why you're so successful gary so
i have to ask you where do you go when
you go on vacation
you know i'm a very completely being
checked out guy meaning beach no wife
like out like just being completely off
the grid
um
that's how i like to do it yeah is there
anywhere in particular you usually go
turks and caicos beautiful uh mykonos
those are two places that stand out for
me i mean
two of the best two of the best well i
hope you get to go on vacation soon but
the vacation is not happening right now
because we are about to play tennis
takedown are you ready i'm ready they're
cheering for you do you hear it thank
you crowd
all right so
let me tell you the rules real quick so
there's going to be one minute on the
clock we asked 100 fans on the grounds
okay five questions okay you want to
guess the most popular i know that game
go ahead yeah so first question what's
the most romantic place at the u.s open
the fountain
what's the best place to vacation
paris what's the best beverage to drink
while watching tennis
honeydews
name the active tennis player you'd most
like to meet
i hate this answer but i'm sure it's
roger federer
what do you love most about yourself
that i'm kind
all right so i think you are going to be
the winner right now but we're gonna
check so we ask you what's the major
magic place at the us open surveys you
said fountains survey says
top answer 46 points we asked what the
best place the vacation is you said
france survey says
nobody said paris crazy out of 100
people that's insane i know new york is
new york is so anti-france i know
because we have clashing personalities i
kind of like that i'm actually happy
right now keep going all right we asked
you what's the best beverage to drink
while watching tennis you said honeydew
survey says it's on the board 12 the top
answer was beer
we asked you to name the active tennis
player you'd most like to meet you did
say federer survey says ding ding ding
top answer with 32 points and final
question what do you love most about
yourself you said your kindness
i want to give it to him because the top
answer was personality interesting 42
points
somebody give me a number what did gary
be for
132 you are sitting at the top of the
leaderboard we are going to get you any
u.s open swag you want i love it thank
you for having me so much i have no
authority to get cheers you do botcha
what's up it's garyvee first of all
thank you so much i hope you're doing
super well during these times uh i also
want to ask you please subscribe because
my commitment and exploration of youtube
is about to explode stories polls more
content more engagement more surprise
and delight
this
is the time to subscribe i hope you
consider it and i hope i see you soon